did you know that one moment on the set
of the Barbie movie left Margot Robbie
mortified did you know that she didn't
think this film would ever make it to
the big screen yeah a lot went into
getting this history making movie off
the ground and we've got all the details
now let's start by dipping our toes in
pun intended to that famous foot
close-up moment Barbie's feet have to be
one of the iconic dolls most
recognizable features the famous feet
were designed to always fit seamlessly
into high heels and as a result they're
always in that super arched shape even
Barefoot when the first trailer for the
Barbie movie hit the internet Margot
Robbie's feet in full Barbie formation
had plenty of folks talking and laughing
out loud so how did they do it well
luckily the star with the now famous
feat broke it down and yes they were in
fact Margot Robbie's feet eyesight
walked up kind of held onto the bar
above camera
so much went into creating Barbie's
dream house from drawings to models and
miniature versions it was pretty
incredible seeing this set for the first
time it was kind of surreal because I'd
spent so long looking at the Miniatures
and the models and the drawings and the
design of what it was going to look like
and then when you see it firsthand in
real life it's all there and it's like I
don't know it's it was really exciting
the house has a slide that goes from the
upstairs into the pool outside as Robbie
says not super practical but nothing is
for Bobby the walls of the house are
entirely open which means that Barbie
has basically no privacy but this is how
Barbie and her fellow Barbies can see
each other all the time everything in
this house is a different shade of pink
even the parts that would typically be
white are an extra pill shade of pink
for the rest of the sets Greta Gerwig
focused on the OG Barbie who was created
in 1959 because Barbie was invented in
1959 it felt like we could ground
everything in that look Gerwig wanted
everything to be beautiful as well as
inspired by Mattel's actual toys not
every iconic aspect of Barbie's history
is gonna be featured in this film many
folks who watched the trailers wondered
where aqua's famous song Barbie Girl was
well it won't be featured in the movie
The Way some folks might want it to but
it is going to be sampled in an original
song by Nicki Minaj and Ice spice for
the Barbie movie soundtrack titled
Barbie world when transforming into
Barbie the Myriad dolls of the film LED
by Margot Robbie needed to use real
Barbies as acting inspiration Robbie
says that she watched old radox
commercials to perfect scenes where
Barbie was showering without water and
how does Barbie Get Around by being
carried of course which is why Barbie
doesn't always walk from place to place
in this movie She floats two replicate
the IRL Barbie's World many things in
this movie are plastic from toothpaste
to the ocean even Barbie's kitchen isn't
entirely real some things are actually
decals just like in the real life
Barbie's dream house according to Robbie
having things that were were obviously
artificial was a goal that's why
Barbie's pool is entirely fake and many
of the sets are actually painted to look
particularly bright Dynamic and of
course like a set now of course Barbie
is the main character in this film
that's why it's called the Barbie movie
and Ken is not in the spotlight in quite
the same way hi Barbie
hi Ken hence the viral marketing that
said she's everything he's just Ken
still we have to give Ryan Gosling some
credit for his portrayal as Barbie's
counterpart when promoting his upcoming
movie The Gray Man Gosling couldn't help
but compare Ken's character with his
character in the gray man who happens to
be a CIA agent with a secret identity
who has a bounty on his head sounds like
a rough situation but according to
Gosling they're Ken life it's even
harder than the gray man life I think
Ken's got no money he's got no job yeah
it's not easy being Ken but what exactly
makes it so hard well Gosling wants you
to see the movie to figure that out for
yourself yes The Man Behind Ken was
tight-lipped about the movie's plot but
so was everyone else even folks working
on set didn't know many of the details
actor Emma Eastwood worked as a body
double for Margot Robbie and according
to Eastwood I was on this for two weeks
and I barely know what the movie's about
she says that the whole team did a very
good job of keeping the plot hidden the
public Mayfield totally in the dark
about some aspects of what exactly this
movie will be about but even many folks
involved in the film are waiting for the
premiere to learn about Barbie's story
now one person who knows all the secrets
Margot Robbie who clearly did an amazing
job of embodying Barbie while also
acting as an executive producer on the
film it's clear from the trailers and
behind the scenes footage that she put
her all into this role and it certainly
paid off even director Greta Gerwig was
amazed by what Robbie was capable of
when it came to getting into her
character according to Gerwig she needed
a scene in which Robbie was moving in
slow motion but the world around her
wasn't she says that she asked Robbie to
move at 48 frames per second while they
shot in 24 frames per second Gerwig says
that after thinking for a moment about
the calculations she literally moved at
a higher frame rate I don't know what
category that goes into other than Magic
oh luckily for Gerwig her magic movie
star was interested in the project from
the jump me but there was one
interesting reason why Robbie didn't
think she'd end up playing the role she
didn't actually think the movie would
get made at all of course they did end
up making the movie in the end and it
pretty quickly caught the attention of
fans but Robbie wasn't crazy about the
attention she got over these images
which you certainly saw on the internet
when they first came out according to
Robbie so many people gathered around
when they caught wind of the movie
filming that she and Gosling were
mortified we look like we're like
laughing having fun but dying on the
inside Greta gerwig's past directing has
earned her plenty of fans and made folks
confident that she's gonna nail the
Barbie movie and the more we hear about
her directing for this film The more
sure of this we are Gerwig wasn't afraid
of thinking outside the box that's
probably how she came up with the idea
for a cast and crew sleepover yep if
working on this movie didn't sound like
fun already just imagine a Barbie movie
sleepover gurwig wanted to give that
feeling to the whole cast and in her
words do something totally girly hey
when in the Barbie Dream House live like
the Barbie Zoo yet gurwig's total
Mastery of getting the Barbie Vibes
exactly right doesn't mean that she
turned Blind Eye to the controversy
surrounding Barbie to the contrary she
wants to turn Barbie on her head in many
ways in Margot Robbie's words people
generally hear Barbie and think I know
what the movie is gonna be and then they
hear that Greta Gerwig is writing and
directing it and they're like oh well
maybe I don't Gerwig has clearly
embraced diversity and feminist themes
for this film but she's also not afraid
to confront Barbie's polarizing history
head-on the tagline if you love Barbie
this movie is for you if you hate Barbie
this movie is for you makes that pretty
easy to see Gerwig is the perfect
director for this film since she loved
Barbies she said I played with dolls for
too long I was still doing it in Junior
High kids were drinking and I was
playing with dolls little did she know
she was actually just preparing for her
future career those of us who like
gerwigs spend our fair share of time
playing with Barbies know that one of
the most important things about Barbie
is her clothes that's why Gerwig simply
had to call on Academy award-winning
costume designer Jenny Bevin to bring
Barbie's wardrobe to life her work on
the film pays homage to Classic Barbie
ensembles and according to her she aimed
for color and Whimsy to make the looks
come to life the great minds behind the
movie also made reference to the toy
with how Barbie's actual closet looks
when she picks out her outfits each
morning now one particularly important
part of Barbie's wardrobe that would be
her accessories of course from pink cat
eye sunglasses that are a throwback to
the early Barbies to those now famous
rollerblades the movie brought many of
Barbie's classic accessories to life
those yellow rollerblades are in fact
based on a real accessory 1994's Hot
skate and Barbie skates and yes there
was a Ken version Barbie fans are
nothing if not impressed by the accuracy
of so many of the film's looks and of
course we're feeling plenty of nostalgia
so are you as excited to see the Barbie
Dream House on the big screen as we are
now what part of this movie are you
looking forward to the most let us know
in the comments and for more videos like
this one like And subscribe to the
things
[Music]